marc
madame monsieur bonsoir voici les titres
de l'actualité de ce dimanche 9 décembre
une tempête hivernale la bretagne la
normandie le littoral des pays de loire
ont été touchés aujourd'hui par des
vents violents
pas de dégâts majeurs mais des
difficultés essentiellement en mer le
bulletin d' alerte de météo france est
maintenue dans 11 départements jusqu'à
demain matin
c'est la question du jour - marc kadhafi
est-il le bienvenu en france le
président libyen est attendu demain à
paris et ce voyage suscite aujourd'hui
la polémique en cause les choix
diplomatiques du président sarkozy à
gauche les critiques se sont multipliées
réaction ce soir sur ce plateau de
bernard henri lévy nous reviendrons
également sur une enquête qui réveille
nos inquiétudes sur le téléphone
portable des scientifiques affirment
qu'il y a un lien de cause à effet entre
le portable le développement de tumeurs
cancéreuses
alors que faut-il croire nous tenterons
ce soir d'y voir un peu plus clair
et si les jeux n'étaient pas faits dans
la course à l'investiture démocrate aux
états unis hillary clinton perd du
terrain sur son adversaire barack obama
le candidat noir américain vient de
recevoir le soutien d'une des femmes les
plus influentes des états unis elle est
la star de la télévision américaine
enfin du cinéma la fin de ce journal
avec si j'étais lui une comédie
française sur une rencontre sociale
inattendue entre un homme désoeuvré et
une femme installée
carole bouquet et marc lavoine sont nos
invités
merci d'être avec nous ce dimanche soir
est on comment ce journal par ces images
de la première tempête hivernale sur
l'ouest du pays et plus précisément sur
la bretagne
l'essentiel des conséquences de ces
fortes rafales de vent étaient au jour
lui ressenti en mer comme vous le voyez
sur ces images un marin est d'ailleurs
tombée de son avenir il est toujours
porté disparu au large des côtes
finistère les vents atteignaient parfois
140 km heure et des creux de plus de dix
mètres ont également été enregistrés
plusieurs bateaux en difficulté ont fait
appel à des équipes de secours le point
sur cette journée avec amaury guibert au
large du finistère un hélicoptère de la
marine nationale en pleine opération de
secours se battent au lituanien est en
panne de moteur une partie de l'équipage
a dû être évacués dans l'après midi
un peu plus loin dans le rail d'ouessant
un marin est porté disparu après être
tombé d'un bateau de commerce
la mer était démontée avec des creux de
10 à 15 mètres
la tempête annoncée a bien tenu ses
promesses les vents en rafales ont
atteint 130 km/heure et les promeneurs
étaient nombreux pour admirer ce
spectacle à l'image de ces rochers
recouvert des cubes comme de la neige à
noël c'est extraordinaire le mess
bretonne ça fait du bien c'est noël déjà
et la promenade du dimanche se mériter
la vie est vraiment belle des gammes à
ses classes et enivrant pour venir en
bretagne pour voir ce à quoi en fait la
bretagne n'a pas eu le monopole de la
tempête
voici les côtes du cotentin cet après
midi plus au sud en vendée toujours les
mêmes images à saisir sur la pellicule
j'en prends un maximum pour avoir ça
parce que c'est assez exceptionnel donc
on en profite pour aujourd'hui
au profi té des belles images
qui ont été d'en faire des belles et
cette tempête plutôt classique pour la
saison va s'attarder sur la côte
atlantique et la manche
météo france maintient son bulletin
d'alerté orange sur onze départements de
l'ouest du pays jusqu'à demain lundi 16h
dans l'actualité également en gironde un
automobiliste a fauché huit cyclistes
qui participaient hier après midi à une
action du téléthon à saint selve trois
personnes ont été blessées gravement et
transporté au chu de bordeaux l'homme
qui était au volant âgé de 33 ans
conduisait en toute illégalité reportage
francis mazoyer bernard bonne arme le
chauffeur un belge de 33 ans n'avait ni
permis de conduire ni assurance
la route était glissante il a dérapé et
fait un tête à queue puis le choc avec
un groupe de cyclistes du téléthon qui
arrivait en face sa 309 a traîné l'un
d'eux sur plusieurs mètres
bilan trois blessés graves dont leur
reste dans un état critique
un des coureurs témoigne il l'a échappé
belle j'ai eu je pense la peur de ma vie
parce que on a eu vraiment un accident
très grave
comme j'étais en tête de groupe j'ai vu
la voiture dérape et est arrivé à ma
hauteur il s'est mis en travers
et puis il a fauché mais mes collègues
qui étaient qui était derrière moi
la compagne du chauffeur rapidement sur
les lieux a invectivé certains cyclistes
une altercation s'est déclenchée bien
que légèrement blessée à la tête
le conducteur s'en est lui même mêlé
tout d'un coup il a sorti une arme à feu
de son véhicule en braquant les
cyclistes donc ça a été la stupéfaction
générale est en fête s'est avéré que
cette arme
heureusement était une arme factice va
nous ne comprenons toujours pas sa
réaction dans sa voiture le conducteur
gardait une batte de baseball et un
couteau à cran d'arrêt le taux
d'alcoolémie s'est avéré négatif mais
les charges sont lourdes
sa garde à vue a été prolongée de 24
heures et autres lieux autres accidents
dans la meuse cette fois un chauffard a
percuté hier un cortège de la saint
nicolas dans un village près de
bar-le-duc
l'accident a fait deux blessés graves
deux enfants après le choc la voiture a
très vite pris la fuite mais l'auteur
présumé l'accident âgé de 80 ans a
finalement pu être interpellé ce matin
justice yvan colonna était en corse
aujourd'hui sous haute surveillance
l'ensemble de la cour d'assises se
déplacer sur l'île de beauté
deux étapes étaient au programme une à
la gendarmerie de pietrosella
c'est là que l'âme qui a servi à tuer le
préfet claude erignac avait été volé
ensuite c'est sur les lieux de
l'assassinât que la cour s'est
rassemblée sur place le reportage
olivier théron et jean-marc donc c'est
un déplacement sous haute tension qui a
commencé ce matin de l'arrière du
transall de l'armée
yvan colonna encadré de policiers du
raid revient en corse 4 ans et demi
après son arrestation un regard vers
l'aéroport et il monte dans un fourgon
cellulaire à pietrosella les abords de
la gendarmerie sont investis par les
forces de l'ordre
le huis clos de l'audience doit être
préservé c'est ici que larmes qui a tué
le préfet erignac a été dérobé yvan
colonna nie avoir participé à
l'opération sous très haute protection
en convoi la cour arrive rue colonna
d'ornano à ajaccio le quartier a été
bouclé
c'est là que le préfet a été assassiné
les magistrats ont attendu la nuit
l'enjeu déterminé en recoupant les
déclarations des témoins le nombre de
tueurs 2 pour les avocats de la défense
un troisième yvan colonna pour
l'accusation et les parties civiles
lorsque monsieur colombani voit deux
personnes le troisième peut parfaitement
être un peu plus loin à gauche il peut
être cachée et monsieur colombani ne le
voit pas cela confirme le fait qu'il
avait bien trois hommes et cela infirme
totalement la thèse de la défense des
conclusions que bien sûr la défense yvan
colonna réfute pour ses avocats il n'y
aurait pas la place pour un troisième
homme
la partie civile oublie une chose c'est
que les murs n'étaient pas vides et
qu'il y avait sur place des véhicules
automobiles et notamment de véhicules
automobiles qui étaient garés en épi et
à côté d'une armoire de bouteilles de
gaz qui fait que la paix aucune personne
ne pouvait être contre le mur il
centaines de personnes curieux ou
sympathisants regardent la scène de loin
parmi elles stéphane colonna ici en vain
d'apercevoir son frère vers 19h30 le
cortège a repris la direction de
l'aéroport et prenons tout de suite la
direction d'ajaccio afin de retrouver
notre envoyée spéciale dominique
verdeilhan bonsoir dominique la question
tout le monde se pose ce soir est de
savoir si ce déplacement le plus cher
peut-être de l'histoire judiciaire aura
une réelle
utilité en tout cas c'est une audience
qui restera dans les mémoires à plus
d'un titre vous l'avez dit d'abord en
raison de son coût une facture de 100
mille euros pour la simple journée alors
bien évidemment de chaque côté de la
barre les avocats sont repartis avec
leurs convictions
j'allais dire renforcée quant à
l'implication ou non
yvan colonna mais aujourd'hui ce qu'il
faut retenir c'est le signe fort que la
corée six spéciales de paris qui est
quand même à plus de mille kilomètres de
son point d'attaché à envoyer aussi bien
la défense que l'accusation
tout a été fait pour que le procès soit
équitable et quel que soit le verdict en
fin de semaine eh bien il aura une
crédibilité
et puis c'est une audience aussi
sûrement qu a été très forte pour yvan
colonna celui qui se qualifie de
patriote corse parce que ce retour au
pays de quelques heures hé bien ça peut
être un avant goût de liberté s'il est
acquitté en fin de semaine mais ça peut
être aussi un dernier voyage avant
longtemps
s'il est condamné merci dominique
parlons maintenant de cette visite qui
apparaît comme de plus en plus
encombrante pour le président sarkozy
demain mouammar kadhafi sera l'invité de
la france et l'accueil du président
libyen n'est pas du goût de tout le
monde ainsi depuis quelques heures de
nombreuses voix et notamment au sein de
l'opposition ses lèvres contre cette
visite
françois bayrou estime qu'elle est
indigne ségolène royal la trouvent
choquante le point avec thiré kurt et
philippe rochot est thomas donzel
depuis hier mouammar kadhafi digne de
nouveau avec les grands d'europe
le colonel président libyen a donc
retrouvé suffisamment de respectabilité
pour être de nouveau fréquentable
ce n'est pas sa première visite à paris
déjà en novembre 73 c'est un georges
pompidou sur ses gardes qu'il reçoit le
chef d'état libyen soutient les groupes
terroristes palestiniens
sa venue provoque la colère des
associations pro israël mais nous sommes
deux mois après la guerre du kippour et
les prix du pétrole flambe ou fou doit
ménager le monde arabe
il a 27 ans lorsqu'il fomenter un coup
d'état qui le portent au pouvoir en 69
son modèle nasser comme lui ils prônent
l'unité arabe
son credo le socialisme basée sur le
coran qu'il met en page dans ce petit
livre vert
son activisme le rend suspect aux yeux
de l'occident
on le soupçonne d'être derrière de
nombreux attentats dont celui de berlin
contre une discothèque
deux soldats américains ont tué en
représailles l'aviation américaine
bombarde son qg à tripoli
sa fille adoptive ahn a été tué dans
l'attaqué la destruction de cette maison
où vivait des enfants est un acte
politique dictée par le mal qui a été
commis par eliane et satcher les
enquêtes le désignent entre autres après
les attentats de lockerbie 270 morts et
contre le dc10 d'uta 170 morts au nom du
chemin parcouru depuis ces familles de
victimes ne s'oppose plus à la venue du
leader libyen à paris il est important
sans doute comme ceux kadhafi soit soit
reçue
c'est important malheureusement pour
nous il faut qu'on accepte mais c'est
important si on ne veut pas que la libye
soit tenté de retourner vers ses vieux
démons
mais ces familles souhaitaient être
reçus par nicolas sarkozy pour ne pas
être oublié
au nom du réalisme économique la
majorité ne voit que de bonnes raisons
pour recevoir le colonel 1 le pays
arrêter son programme nucléaire
militaire de il coopère complètement
avec les services occidentaux sur la
lutte contre le terrorisme
3 il s'ouvre développement international
je ne vois pas comment la france
pourrait pas participer à ça et fermé la
porte
sol d'ailleurs est la libye alors que
d'autres participent au développement de
ce pays
mais à gauche on n'oublie pas comment le
pouvoir libyen a instrumentalisé la
sphère des infirmières bulgares que des
relations seraient établissent avec la
libye oui de là à lui offrir les champs
elysées lui donner une centrale
nucléaire des armes de très hautes
le capacité cela nous ne sommes pas
d'accord
le colonel kadhafi restera six jours à
paris une visite qui dérange des voix
qui s'élèvent c'est la question du jour
le président libyen est il oui ou non le
bienvenu ce soir notre invité est
bernard henri lévy bonsoir merci d'être
avec nous la question est simple est-ce
que cette visite est une erreur pour la
france c'est une erreur et c'est même
incompréhensible parce que il s'agit pas
d'être les premiers à lui fermer la
porte nous sommes les premiers à le
recevoir et à recevoir en grande pompe
et lorsque nicolas sarkozy dit qu'il a
changé mais c'est faux c'est faux il n'a
pas renoncé au terrorisme
pas plus tard qu'avant-hier à lisbonne à
la tribune d'une université il nous
disait que le terrorisme était
justifiable
lorsqu'il les larmes des faibles ce qui
le vieil argument ddd soutiennent
niteroi et puis quand même la sphère des
infirmières bulgares
ce n'est pas le prix à payer jusqu'à
demain l affaire des infirmières
bulgares quand on prend cinq otages qu
on les torture qu'on l'ait martyrise
pendant des années et qu'on les
rencontre rançon ça s'appelle comment
sinon du terrorisme donc il ya encore
quatre mois
nicolas sarkozy le sait mieux que
personne puisqu'il a libéré les
infirmières mais c'est pas le cas de la
fille se comporter comme un terreau et
cette libération n'est pas le
prix à payer c'est probablement le prix
à payer à 100 à ce moment là qu'on le
dise clairement qu'on lui dise
clairement
mais qu'on ne vienne pas nous dire que
kadhafi est sur le chemin de sa
rédemption car c'est inexact
il faut appeler les choses il faut
appeler un chat un chat kadhafi n'a pas
renoncé au terrorisme
il ya quelques mois encore dans la
sphère des infirmières il se conduisait
comme un preneur d'otages c'est à dire
comme un terroriste donc on s'apprête à
recevoir en mettant les petits plats
dans les grands en le plu permettant
peut-être d'aller se recueillir sur la
tombe du général de gaulle
le financier du terrorisme des années 80
qui n'a de son propre aveu pas renoncer
au terrorisme europe est-ce que vous
porter le même jugement sur la
diplomatie de nicolas sarkozy concernant
de la lumière poutine
concernant le régime chinois où il ya
une différence oui je trouve même qu'il
ya là comme je vous le disais quelque
chose inexplicable un président qui
s'applique avec beaucoup d'honnêteté à
nous dire que sur tous les terrains ce
qui l'a promis il le fera sur les
régimes spéciaux sur la croissance sur
le chômage était il ya un domaine où il
ne tient pas parole c'est affaire de
droits de l'homme et ses affaires de
politique étrangère la forme m étais
avec le président iranien ahmadinedjad
le seul à téléphoner à vladimir poutine
pour le féliciter du résultat des
élections qui ont des noms notamment 99
% de votants en tchétchénie mais vous
êtes peut-être vous dans votre position
de philosophe lui les présidents
effectivement il applique une
realpolitik et celle de faire signer des
contrats n'êtes pas d'accord avec ça 6
mais bien entendu que il faudrait aller
regarder ce que font les allemands
regardent et angela merkel l'allemagne
signent des contrats mais ont elles ne
donnent pas pour autant à kadhafi cette
extraordinaire blason cette
extraordinaire reconnaissance symbolique
qu'est la mascarade à laquelle on va
assister dans les jours qui viennent
il ya un parfum quand même dans cette
affaire de deux comédies si ce n'était
tragique et s'il n'y avait là bas en
libye des prisonniers politiques une
dictature féroce
vous êtes troublé par la place de votre
ami bernard kouchner au sein de ce
gouvernement
oui je suis troublé surtout jusqu'à
présent par son par son silence
assourdissant il diluée dans une
interview qui n'est pas question
d'oublier les victimes à imputer à
kadhafi que la france garde les yeux
ouverts
oui bah ça c'est bien s'il dit ça dans
une interview qui vont de l'apparaître
jeu d'origine
demain eh bien eh bien c est bien c'est
bien parce que l'inventeur de médecins
sans frontières un quai bernard kouchner
ce militant des droits de l'homme ne
peut pas accepter que la france devienne
cette espèce de 2,2 de blizzard pays où
on reçoit les assassins et où on
félicite les tortionnaires par téléphone
ça n'est pas possible et il ya une
différence lors qu'on tisse des liens
avec des personnages controversés comme
hugo chavez pour libérer ingrid
betancourt moi je dis surtout il faut
relire inlassablement la lettre d'ingrid
betancourt où elle dit que la france et
son président sont le méridien de
l'histoire ils sont des millions de par
le monde des résistants comme une fille
bettencourt qui croient en la france qui
pense que la france et les droits de
l'homme qui pense que la france est le
pays qui défend les libertés et moi je
crois qu'en faisant ce qu'on fait là
c'est à dire en en recevant demain le
président kadhafi à paris et pendant ces
cinq interminables jours ont trahis
l'espérance de ces de ces gens de ces
dissidents l'espérance qui met dans la
france mais ça je pense que c'est pas
bien merci bernard henri lévy l'avenir
justement d'ingrid betancourt est au
coeur du déplacement de françois fillon
en argentine le premier ministre qui
participe à l'investiture de la nouvelle
présidente cristina kirchner souhaite
que tous les états de la région jouent
de leur influence afin de tenter de
trouver une issue positive au sort des
otages ont soit fillon qui a rencontré
la mère d'ingrid betancourt à buenos
aires sur place nos envoyés spéciaux
alix bouilhaguet et arnaud justine
voilà pour l'image officielle de
françois fillon en argentine des visites
qui s'enchaînent comme ce centre emmaüs
de la banlieue de buenos aires côté
coulisses c'est le sort d'ingrid
betancourt qui mobilise le premier
ministre d'après son entourage il n'y a
jamais eu autant d'espoirs de libérer
l'otage aux mains de la guérilla
colombienne des farc depuis 2002 et la
france entend bien peser dans les
négociations belle du président de la
république l'appel à la communauté
internationale qui manifestement est
entendu en particulier par le président
colombien
c'est un appel un geste humanitaire
immédiat de la part des farc
la france étant disponible ensuite pour
continuer à travailler à des solutions
pacifiques aux à la libération des
autres otages
demain toute l'amérique latine un
rendez-vous à buenos aires pour
l'investiture de la nouvelle présidente
cristina kirchner en marge des
cérémonies le premier ministre va
rencontrer tous les principaux chefs
d'état de la région du vénézuélien hugo
chavez au colombien alvaro uribe
une véritable tribune pour intensifier
la médiation française ici à buenos
aires la stratégie française concernant
ingrid betancourt équerre impliqués dans
cette affaire un maximum de chefs d'état
d'amérique latine pour sortir du face à
face entre la guérilla des farc et le
président colombien
il s'appelle barack obama il est
candidat à l'investiture démocrate dans
la course à la maison blanche elle
s'appelle oprah winfrey elle est la star
numéro un de la télévision américaine
une des femmes les plus influentes de
l'amérique d'aujourd'hui et son appel à
voter pour le candidat noir américain
arrive à un moment clé de la campagne
pour la première fois hillary clinton ne
semble plus aussi invincible
l'explication sur place alain de
chalvron aaron dimon elle n'a l'air de
rien et pourtant elle fait la pluie le
beau temps aux états unis
elle a reçu sur son plateau le ban et
l'arrière-ban de l'amérique
la seule mention dans son émission
d'anna karénine a fait du livre de
tolstoï un bestel son engagement actif
en faveur de barack obama aujourd'hui
pourrait donner aux candidats le coup de
pouce dont il a besoin
je suis ici en raison de ma profonde
conviction personnelle en faveur de
barack obama et de ce qu'il peut faire
pour l'amérique face à la star du petit
écran le sénateur fait le modeste
je sais bien que beaucoup d'entre vous
ne sont venus ici que pour oprah je suis
que sortent de ce produit mais ils
engrangent il est en train de remonter
son retard sur hillary clinton
nationalement le fossé toujours très
important une vingtaine de points mais
il est désormais légèrement en tête en
iowa le premier état où l'on va voter
dans trois semaines
une victoire là bas pourrait renverser
la dynamique frais est incroyablement
populaire auprès de la ménagère blanche
de plus de 50 ans issus des classes
populaires
le profil exact de l'électorat moyen de
la wii l'enjeu principal est ce qu
apporte au prat c'est cet électorat
féminin
le point fort d'hillary clinton la
sénatrice a d'ailleurs bien senti le
danger faisant monter sur scène pour la
première fois sa mère et sa fille
oprah pourrait également aider obama
auprès de l'électorat noir qui
paradoxalement il lui aussi acquis à
hillary clinton
la remontée de barack obama créer un
suspense inattendue dans le processus
électoral comme si les jeux n'étaient
pas faits et c'est vrai aussi chez les
républicains
quel statut pour le kosovo cette
province où la population à 90%
libanaise réclament toujours son
indépendance à cela s'oppose la minorité
serbe
voilà résumée la tension qui existe
depuis la fin de la guerre dans cette
région et demain à bruxelles l'europe
constatera l'échec des pourparlers
engagés pour une solution négociée une
solution risquée la question
communautaire est toujours sensible
voici l'exemple de ce qu'est le kosovo
un monastère orthodoxe isolé en terre
albanophones et musulmane protégé par
des soldats français
c'est le grand format de ce soir il est
signé
lionel feierstein et patrick desmulie
cela fait huit ans que la guerre est
finie mais rien n'a changé à des beach
le monastère orthodoxe reste toujours
sous la protection d'une trentaine de
militaires français
car derrière ces murs vite autour de la
mer anastasia une petite communauté
serbe de six religieuses une communauté
maintes fois attaquées durant la guerre
mais aussi plus récemment cette partie
du monastère comme celles que vous avez
vu avant a été complètement détruite en
2004 lors des dernières émeutes
ici il ne restait que des murs en pierre
rien d'autre l'armée française présente
sur place a juste eu le temps d'évacuer
ces religieuses attention ma ceinture la
foule a commencé à augmenter et de plus
à monter le sommet qui se trouve juste
au du monastère et adam lancé des
cocktails molotov a commencé à avancer
les cocktails molotov
donc ils ont privilégié de sécuriser les
bonnes soeurs il on sortait les bonnes
soeurs du monastère et les albanais donc
ont brûlé sur le monastère
une grande partie des icônes a été volé
ou jetés au fond du puits cet été des
légionnaires français ont réussi à en
récupérer une partie mais trois ans
après la mer anastasia ne comprend
toujours pas la furie des albanais car
ils avaient l'habitude de venir au
monastère ce saint est prévu aussi dans
tout le kosovo et en serbie
même ceux qui ont détruit brûlé notre
monastère le 17 mars venait prier ici et
obtenez tout ce qu'il voulait grâce à
lui les moniales de des beach dispose de
peu de ressources pour vivre
en été elle s'occupe de leur potager en
hiver elles fabriquent ces petits objets
qui seront ensuite exportés et revendus
sur les marchés en serbie
nous ce qu'on veut c'est simplement
vivre en paix dans ce monastère
c'est la vie qu'on a choisi malgré la
situation politique les soeurs souhaite
continuer à vivre à des beach même en
cas de déclaration d'indépendance du
kosovo
elle refuse d'être évacués il existe une
demi-douzaine de monastère comme
celui-ci gardé par la kfor et monastères
qui ont tous été pris pour cible lors
des dernières émeutes de 2004 car pour
les albanais il représente toujours le
symbole même de la présence serbe au
kosovo aux états unis pour la quatrième
fois depuis jeudi le lancement de la
navette atlantis a été reporté en raison
d'une anomalie technique pour l'instant
inexpliquée une nouvelle tentative a été
fixé cette fois au 2 janvier prochain je
vous rappelle que le spationaute
français léopold eyharts tu fais partie
de cette mission vers la station
spatiale internationale
ce mystère maintenant qui n'est toujours
pas élucidé le meurtre d'une française
sur l'île moustique pour est resté une
énigme
dix ans après l'assassinât de suzanne
moss berger sur cette île paradisiaque
des caraïbes
l' enquête vient de conclure un non-lieu
des suspects mais pas de coupable une
scène de crime non protégés voilà les
raisons d'une enquête
raté lionel first and et alexis delcourt
ce sont les dernières images de suzy
moss berger elles ont été prises par sa
nièce quelques mois avant sa mort sur
l'île moustique
un petit paradis pour milliardaires
david bowie mick jagger et la famille
royale d'angleterre y séjourner
régulièrement
c'est là que la riche héritière
alsacienne a été assassiné en 1998 un
meurtre mystérieux jamais élucidé près
de dix ans après la justice française
clos l'anc est un non lieu que sa
famille encore du mal à accepter
tant qu'on ne sait pas qui a fait ça le
travail de deuil complet ne peut pas
être terminée c'est impossible
moi j'ai eu j'ai vu des photos qui sont
insoutenables
c'est dramatique c'est impuni c'est
difficile à supporter
suzie most berger a été retrouvé dans
cette villa louée 10000 euros la semaine
son corps était lardé d'une douzaine de
coups de couteau
mais pas de trace de sévices sexuels
l'essentiel de ces affaires sera
retrouvé dans sa chambre sa famille ne
lui connaît aucun ennemi mais elle a
toujours été intrigué par la présence à
ses côtés de cet homme un jeune serbe de
30 ans son cadet ma belle soeur voulait
terminer son observation est que cet
homme dont elle savait qu'ils étaient
avec elle pour des raisons financières
et l'équipement il a d'ailleurs admis
lui même par la suite et elle voulait le
quitter
dans son testament la riche est la
sienne lui a légué près de 400000 euros
l'homme a été placé en garde à vue puis
relâchés son alibi il était en suisse au
moment du meurtre
depuis aucune autre piste n'aboutit
crime de rôdeur ou affaires financières
aujourd'hui seul un élément nouveau peut
rouvrir le dossier
la loi prévue dix ans avant que la ferme
aux bergers ne soit classée voilà
maintenant l'une des premières études
scientifiques publiées qui démontre que
l' usage du téléphone portable a des
effets nocifs sur la santé
cette question nous inquiète tous mais
elle développe souvent tous les
fantasmes alors que dit cette enquête
explication nathalie sapina et charles
enderlin ils sonnent en permanence et
n'importe où le téléphone portable 53
millions d'utilisateurs en france qui
conversent durant 600 millions d'heures
par an et pour la première fois une
étude suggère un lien entre téléphones
portables et développement de tumeurs
des glandes parotides ces glandes
salivaires qui affleure juste au dessous
de l'oreille à 5 mm de profondeur donc
touché directement par les radiations
émises par le portable
nous sommes à un stade où nous avons
suffisamment d'indications pour
commencer à étayer les soupçons sur les
risques du portable pect ssangyong
l'étude financée par l'organisation
mondiale de la santé montre un risque
accrû pour les gros utilisateurs plus de
20 heures par mois qui téléphonent
toujours du même côté longuement et en
zone rurale où les émissions sont plus
puissantes vapeur c'est moins d'une
heure par jour et de l'as je pense qu'il
ya beaucoup de gens notamment beaucoup
de jeunes qui utilisent leur téléphone
portable au moins une heure par jour
mais en plus toutes les campagnes
promotionnelles sont faites pour
encourager toujours plus d'utilisation
du portable et 2 et wii nitoo je crois
vraiment que nous devons réfléchir
sérieusement à la façon de diminuer
l'exposition de la population aux
radiations de toute la population en
particulier en utilisant davantage les
kits mains libres
quant à la traque des éventuels d'effets
nocifs du portable
elle se poursuit avec de nombreuses
études en cours notamment sur les
tumeurs du cerveau social faut-il
s'attendre cette semaine de nouvelle
journée noire dans les transports et
bien les journées de mercredi la ratp de
jeudi la sncf seront en tout cas
perturber la cgt la cfe cgc ont déposé
un préavis de grève de 24 heures pour
ces jours là le ministre du travail
xavier bertrand a estimé je cite qu'une
nouvelle journée de grève n'est pas
nécessaire pour faire entendre pour ce
faire en temps nous comprendre dans ce
dossier la semaine sociale sera
également marquée par l'annoncé demain
de la mise en vente de 40 mille
logements hlm par an alors locataire il
ya quatre millions et demi de logements
sociaux en français nicolas sarkozy
avait promis pendant la campagne qu'il
vendrait 1% de ce parc immobilier chaque
année diego garcia thomas nous allons
rencontrait de familles qui sont déjà
propriétaires de leur logement social
c'est un peu noël tous les jours depuis
que madame clay a acheté son appartement
janvier dernier 85 mètres carrés qu'elle
occupe depuis 1976 avec ses enfants
après trente ans de location elle est
devenue une propriétaire heureuse
ça faisait longtemps que j'étais dans
l'appartement on l'a proposé quand même
un prêt assez intéressant pour l'achat
combien frais de notaire compris 82000
impôts et l'appartement vos deux cent
mille euros après une bonne affaire
réservée aux locataires de logements
sociaux
une façon d'aider les revenus modestes à
devenir propriétaires ces ventes existe
depuis 1990 mais elle reste trop peu
nombreuse aux yeux du gouvernement
autre exemple dans ce petit pavillon du
val d'oise madame votre âge là occupé
pendant 24 ans en tant que locataire
avant de l'acheter cette année et être
propriétaire ça change tout qui pour ne
laisser rien j'ai rien qu'à acheter
donc c'est vrai que pour moi ça me
libère donne beaucoup de soucis mais les
ventes d'appartements hlm tournent
parfois la catastrophe les accédants
n'ont pas toujours les moyens de
rembourser leurs emprunts et de faire
face aux gros travaux d'entretien pour
éviter le surendettement
le nouveau dispositif prévoit un
accompagnement et même plus en cas de
force majeure en cas d'accidents graves
de la vie chômage décès il y aura auprès
des personnes en difficulté une garantie
de rachat est une garantie de relogement
l'accord conclu entre le gouvernement et
les sociétés hlm prévoit la vente de 40
mille appartements par an et pour
maintenir un parc locatif
le produit des ventes devrait servir à
la construction de nouveaux logements
que s'est-il passé ce week-end dans
l'actualité sportive les derniers
résultats de football du rugby avec la
victoire du stade français en coupe
d'europe
quelques nouvelles de laure manaudou et
une ceinture de champion du monde en
boxe pour brahim asloum
tour d'horizon avec ta taille de
rincquesen voilà sait-on qu'il attendait
cet instant
hier soir sur le ring de cannes et
brahim asloum a rendu coup pour coup au
tenant du titre l'argentin rêver qu pas
de chaos
mais des directs qui font mal les juges
ne s'y sont pas trompés asloum était
déjà champion olympique
le voilà champion du monde de la
catégorie mouche
un but chacun un point chacun cet après
midi nice et bordeaux ont fait match nul
un résultat qui leur permet de
grappiller une place au classement nice
est désormais 7e bordeaux remonte à la
troisième place
le stade français est sorti vainqueur du
duel des buteurs engagé cet après midi
face à cardiff
hernandez et skréla ont passé quatre
pénalités contre deux aux gallois les
parisiens s'imposent 12 à 6 en quelques
heures benjamin stasiulis est devenu
l'attraction principale des championnats
de france de natation
d'abord parce qu'ils nagent vite ensuite
parce qu'il est le nouveau petit copain
de laure manaudou
ce week-end la championne française est
apparu détendu elle a même rigolé avec
philippe lucas
de bonne augure en cette année olympique
de la neige du brouillard
la responsabilité des organisateurs de
cette descente hier à aspen semble bel
et bien engagée dans la chute
d'anne-sophie barthet la skieuse
française est sortie de la piste
elle souffre d'une rupture des ligaments
à l'issue de son accident les
organisateurs ont décidé d'arrêter la
course un peu tard visiblement la page
cinéma de ce dimanche avec une comédie
romantique et social signé anne marie
etienne le titre si c'était lui
une femme auteure à succès rencontre sur
son palier un homme qui souhaite
l'appartement de son oncle à femmes
c'est carole bouquet l'homme désespéré
c'est marc lavoine ils sont nos invités
mais avant cela
extraits la semaine prochaine les
organise comme chaque année un petit
apéritif pour tous les voisins et jeudi
à 19 heures alors la même pente
les voisins crois je retrouve mon
associé me suffit j'ai doublé raté alors
peut-être pas présent d aborder
attendait n'a pas un qui m'a dit bonjour
depuis je suis là pour marquer je
préfère ça à ceux qui font semblant
vous avez complètement on a rien été
cette fois premier coup d'oeil le
premier collège est souvent lent priori
gerima d'yssingeaux tout le bouquin ça
aide a priori les barrières sociales
tout le bordel journée sur lequel les
gens comme moi réfléchissent ceux qui
les subissent pour toi oui bermond moi
je fais des efforts c'est ça oui vous
avez besoin de faire des efforts pour
parler à un mec comme moi bah moi parler
ça me vient tout seul si je le sens
givré si je le sens pas je n'ai pas
visiblement ça faisait bien réussi
jusqu'ici
soyez tranquilles à partir de maintenant
je ferai comme je sers moi aussi je vous
dirai plus bonjour je serais comme vous
hautaine et méprisante ça ma prison de
vous l'étiez déjà vous oubliez votre
robe de mariée et une nappe carole
bouquet marc lavoine bonsoir merci
d'être avec nous alors carole bouquet
apparemment les premiers contacts entre
cette femme et son voisin sont pas au
beau fixe
c'était un peu tendu oui c'est ces deux
mondes qui se rencontrent ces deux
mondes qui se rencontrent c'est surtout
comme d'habitude aux autres c'est à dire
l'autre en fait il vous dérange vous
bouscule y correspond assez c'est
quelqu'un qui chaque vie surtout si on
n'a pas 20 ans elles au fond elle est
organisée
quel que soit parce que lui aussi au
fond je le bouscule on et voilà on est
on s'agace l'un l'autre on se trouve
intolérable et en même temps forcément
on est attirés l'un par l'autre parce
que comme on se ressemblent pas il ya
des frictions et en même temps c'est
attrayant car c'est nous les milices
sentimentale social social et gagner oui
ça parle du vivre ensemble quoi qu'est
ce qu'un homme qui a tout perdu peut
rencontrer une femme qui a presque tout
est quelque chose du monde peut-être et
c'est ça qui se passe entre eux c'est à
dire que est ce que c'est possible
aujourd'hui dans notre société que des
gens si différents fasse tomber des
barrières pour se rencontrer devenir
amis car le bouquet qu'est ce qui vous
attire finalement dans cet homme un peu
à la dérive
c'est pas le fait qu'ils soient là
terrible c'est qu'ils soient absolument
charmant en fait et aussi peut-être
odieux avec elle à dire qu'ils y
répondent
il ya peut-être ça aussi c'est elle
c'est que voilà il a une manière de lui
faire la cour qui est un peu
particulière et qui n'a pas l'habitude
alors qu'est ce qu'il a fait il a tout
perdu son appartement son boulot et
espace la forte demande son nom
sa femme aussi ils squattent à côté et
puis il rencontre le fils de carole et
le chat de carole les personnages que
joe cayrol à travers les yeux de
l'enfant c'est vrai que ça pour ça nous
pose des questions à nous les adultes
les adultes que nous sommes nous dans
nos dans nos convictions nos certitudes
on pense que l'autre est en danger et
les voilà et c'est cette personne qui
nous qui nous réunit dans la vie vous
pensez qu'en france on cherche à
connaître qui est de l'autre côté du
couloir son voisin en somme moi non plus
pas vraiment je veux dire on laissait
vrai qu'encore une fois il faut faire
les efforts je dirais c'est pas naturel
c'est pas évident c'est et elle elle
professe ça fait des années qu'elle
écrit qu'elle réfléchisse sur pour dire
le contraire de ce qui se ressemble
s'assemble
c'est son rôle à cesson c'est son cheval
de bataille et en fait elle est
confrontée tout d'un coup à une réalité
où il a mais devant devant ses propres
contradictions parce que parce qu'en
fait elle pense à hélices a alors que
donc elle est tiraillée en permanence
par partie parce nous stick là qui parce
que c'est sa maladie c'est comme du
poids il ya vous êtes heureuse on vous
propose désormais plus de comédie oui le
mieux moi j'adore ça c'est très
difficile à faire
parfait pour les acteurs à écrire en
tous les cas parce que de parler de
choses graves légèrement ya rien de
mieux parce que c'est vrai que sinon
vous fait peur aux gens sur des sujets
un peu difficile alors que en riant on
peut avoir une liberté de ton formidable
et vous marque cinéma chanson chanson
cinéma
oui oui moi ce qui m'a bouleversé
d'ailleurs il faudrait quand même match
moi je peux pas chanter il était moins
riche que lui fait tout fait lorsqu'il
m'a plu dans ce scénario avancé de juin
carole et florence c'est vrai que ce
sont de grandes actrices le rendu reste
il m'en parlait en sursis qui est
vraiment géniale qui joue la soeur à
petit ça de carole dans le film
et puis
c'est des films qui nous rappelle aussi
à notre vie quotidienne chez caroll est
engagée dans des mouvements importants
depuis très longtemps et moi aussi
et donc c'est vrai que ces films là nous
rattrape un peu par la manche et nous
disent voilà on peut aussi mettre sur
l'écran des choses qui nous traversent
dans la vie on est bouleversé néo par
des sentiments et on peut aussi
s'apercevoir que même dans ces milieux
dans lesquels on côtoie des gens et on
rit avec on a besoin de rire ensemble et
de vivre ensemble ce film explique
peut-être aussi cette rencontre n'est
pas fortuite c'est vrai qu'on on s'est
rencontré sur des idées des thèmes qui y
vivent et des valeurs qui nous
rassemblent mai et puis à travers le
rire et à travers le rire parce que
c'est assez
c'est moi ça m'est nécessaire comme
l'eau que je bois mais sinon j'ai comme
la nourriture le rire le rire n'est
nécessaire glénat vivez vos combos
également merci à tous les
si c'était lui sort sur les écrans donc
mercredi un film signé anne marie
etienne comme chaque dimanche désormais
nous faisons le point sur le box office
justement et des sorties cinéma de la
semaine en france
en tête depuis mercredi à la croisée des
mondes avec nicole kidman puis un bon
début pour l'auberge rouge film français
avec josiane balasko et gérard jugnot
tous à l'ouest avec lambert wilson et
enfin cowboys avec benoît poelvoorde
informations fournies par nos confrères
d'écran total et puis on retrouve à
bénévent votre sim très vite à
l'affichage de ce box couteau avant de
refermer journal retour sur les images
du jour ce sont celles de la tempête qui
a touché les côtes bretonnes et
essentiellement le large du finistère
un marin tombé d'un navire est toujours
porté disparu plusieurs bateaux pris
dans des creux de plus de dix mètres ont
perdu une partie de leur cargaison
les vents ont atteint parfois 140 km
heure
aujourd'hui voilà pour l'actualité de ce
dimanche merci de nous avoir suivis dans
un instant à météo isabelle martinez
20h50 du cinéma avec insomnia al pacino
robin williams pour tooway dès demain
pour la formation
elise lucet à 13h et david pujadas à 20
heures à vendredi et belle semaine à
vous
l'info en continu s'est tassée sur
france 2 point fr votre nom